commence donc avec ce procès procès
pénal
pour bernard tapie vous savez qu'il ya
eu une décision d'arbitrage pour
indemniser bernard tapie de 400 millions
d'euros à la suite d'un truc compliqué
une vente d'adidas par le crédit
lyonnais bref je vous la fait courte
cette décision a été cassée par la
justice tapie a été condamné à
rembourser l'argent mais ça c'est le
côté civil
il ya aussi un volet pénal pour savoir
si il s'est rendu coupable ou non
d'escroquerie et de détournement de
fonds publics
et bien voici sa réponse lui considère
que un c'est pas juste et que deux
compte tenu de son état c'est vraiment
difficile à vivre
il répétait ce matin chez nos confrères
d'rtl après préfet plus personne pourra
dire que tapie l'a gagné 4,34 millions à
l'occasion d'un arbitrage celui qu'il
paiera aura un procès en diffamation
on mélange les relents qu'on me devait
et l'argent de l'arbitrage a fait beau
alors seule certitude ce qu'on pourra
pas dire que j'écoutais de la langue
contribuables oui ça change donc rien de
portage je suis assez heureux que cette
série j'aurais préféré évidemment le
livre en parfait de tempé mais on reçoit
l upa et là avant de lancer le débat je
vous propose maintenant d'écouter benoît
chabert c'est l'avocat du consortium de
réalisation c'est à dire la partie
adverse c'est un organisme qui était de
2 2 en orbite du crédit lyonnais et lui
dit il faut se méfier de bernard tapie
parce que c'est un grand séducteur je
suis un avocat et toujours la
présomption d'innocence se joue mais
l'avocat de la partie civile que je suis
peut dire que d'un art qui est un escroc
et qu ainsi un escroc va arriver à
attirer à lui toutes les personnes
possibles et inimaginables qui
finalement tombe dans le jeu et dans la
séduction
alors est ce que ces personnes ont
parfaitement connaissance de ce son qui
pardon ces personnes ne vous parler mais
ça peut être les gens à l'elysée non ça
peut être vous ça peut être moins ça
peut être n'importe quelle personne
autour de lui maxime des galets je le
disais cette histoire est abominablement
compliqué ça fait quoi une vingtaine
d'années d'ailleurs que ça que ça dure
mais quel est votre intime conviction
sur sur le personnage tapie est ce que
c'est une victime
est ce que c'est un escroc génial
c'est un homme de talent ça c'est sûr et
il démontre une fois de plus puisque on
parle finalement pas du vrai sujet qui
est le sujet de ce procès la question
aujourd'hui n'est pas de rejouer la
partie
des péripéties qui ont pu exister entre
le crédit lyonnais et bernard tapie à
une époque là comme vous l'avait indiqué
le sujet c'est que l'arbitrage a été
annulé par la justice parce qu'il a été
considéré comme vicié les 400000
exactement et là la question qui est
posée c'est effectivement est ce que
cette fraude
il y à une escroquerie dont bernard
tapie serait le principal acteur on a on
peut imaginer que oui maintenant ça va
être à la justice de le déterminer par
contre on peut remarquer une fois de
plus que bernard tapie a un talent
indéniable pour semer de la confusion y
compris sur l'objet même de ceux de ce
procès alors ce qui est vrai c'est que
marc tapie est malade il a un cancer
grave il parle d'ailleurs de sa santé à
l'occasion de ce procès judith waintraub
est ce que vous êtes surprise par le le
mode de défense de bernard tapie voté
journaliste politique c'est quelqu'un
que vous suivez depuis depuis longtemps
n'ont pas surprise c'est un c'est un
homme qui tue qui parle très ouvertement
de lui où il mélange toujours plusieurs
plans le plan affectif le plan politique
le plan financier en l'occurrence
souvent il a devant lui des
interlocuteurs et j'en suis une qui sont
pas très au fait de toutes les arcanes
du dossier proprement dit quand on le
regarde on s'aperçoit que
le crédit lyonnais à l'époque bande
public et a eu un comportement tout à
fait tout à fait discutable ça explique
en partie d'ailleurs pourquoi leur
métrage a été rendue dans un premier
temps en faveur de bernard tapie crédit
lyonnais a fait a fait une plus value
extraordinaire au vent dont un revendeur
adidas principal créancier du sud on
s'est lâché en étant à la fois arbitre
et partick enfin joueurs et joueurs et
arbitres donc et ça je trouve qu'on en a
peu parlé
donc on verra bien christine lagarde a
été condamné par la cour de justice pour
négligence elle a été dispensé une peine
mais quand même la cour de justice a
estimé qu'elle n'avait pas fait son
boulot en demandant pas un recours
contre la décision d'accor on rappelle
qu'à l'époque c'était un quinquennat
nicolas sarkozy christine lagarde
ministre de l'économie donc chargé de
veiller à ce que les décisions prises
sarkozy était favorable avec un tapis et
toutes celles qui ont été prises ensuite
sous quinquennat de françois hollande
lui ont été défavorables évidemment ça a
créé dit gravement l'idée de collusion
politique parce que le personnage un
charme fou parce que quand vous
l'entendez parler des banlieues de son
expérience de son enfance pauvre
je vois philippe bailly hausse est
sensible moi je les ai vus en action
j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de trappes et par
une certaine sincérité et d'ailleurs
l'honnêteté et la sincérité sont deux
choses différentes comme on a pu le voir
c'est difficile de trancher
oui c'est le l'avocat du cdr disent
attention beaucoup de gens tombent dans
le jeu et dans la séduction ferghana
ziari vous êtes séduit par le personnage
tapis la fin d'appui de mon point de vue
c'est une très vieille histoire ça
remonte quand même à quelques dizaines
de jeux dès maintenant à peine n'est
donc j'ai découvert en fait cette
affaire au fil du temps en lisant en
lisant et c'est vrai que j'ai été assez
étonné par cette affaire on parle alors
d'affaires tapis mais avec ce ce cette
distinction un peu manichéenne avec
bernard tapie coupable l'état qui serait
victime et donc qui se constitue partie
civile
ça me semble quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça puisque ici on a quand
même des responsables politiques des
responsables publics qui ont été aux
commandes qui ont validé certaines
procédures qui auraient éventuellement
négliger certains aspects de la
procédure qui aurait coûté énormément
d'argent aux contribuables mais là
encore pourquoi comment cela est-il
possible
simplement parce que comme ce n'est pas
l'argent en fait des décideurs publics
qui peuvent se permettre effectivement
d'être d'être négligents on ne verrait
pas je sais pas moi une multinationale
condamné à verser plusieurs millions
d'euros ne pas faire appel ne pas tenter
de te faire annuler une décision qui lui
est défavorable donc cette affaire ne me
paraît pas blanc ou noir maintenant d'un
à tapis escrocs victimes ça serait pas
mal de le dire c'est à dire que
l'affairé est en cours et même si je
sais bien qu'on n'est pas sensé
commenter une décision de justice en
cours
c'est quand même difficile donc on
n'avait pas rendu on peut commenter mais
c'est quand même difficile de ne pas
imaginer que la sphère est quelque part
déjà un peuplier puisqu'on l'a dit tout
à l'heure la sphère du
du simulacre de d'arbitrage a été jugé
en civil on a considéré effectivement
que ce cette procédure était
complètement vicié
donc moi j'ai du mal comment aujourd'hui
les juges peuvent dissocier un peu le
civil du pinet même si en théorie et une
autonomie des procédures pénales par
rapport aux civils enfin dans l'opinion
publique y est aux yeux de beaucoup de
juristes cette affaire semble semble
payer pour lui donc ça va si on descend
encore un peu plus dans le détail on
peut dire que là ce procès où il est
soupçonné d'escroquerie
parce que en fait il aurait un peu
organisés le l'arbitrage en prenant
contact avec les arbitres un petit peu
avant on rappelle que quand il ya un
arbitrage et bien tout le monde doit
accepter la décision et qui a plus de
procédures d'appel classique philippe
meyer est ce que vous êtes séduit babin
arta piste d'un personnage de roman
écoutez le débat judiciaire va régler la
question de la culpabilité de bernard
tapie dans cette affaire maintenant
retour en arrière christophe bouchet
journalistes l afp publie une biographie
de bernard tapie pourquoi parce que il
est à l'époque à marseille chargés de
suivre entre autres l'om et que tous les
renseignements qu'on lui donne sur
bernard tapie sa date de naissance on ne
laisse en rien le concorde et il décide
donc il fait une enquête son enquête
montre que en ce qui concerne son
enfance dans la tapie a considérablement
réécrit le réécrit l'histoire
ensuite bernard tapie plus tard dans sa
carrière rachète vont des relais piles
électriques quand ils rachètent vont
d'air raconte christophe bouchet il
réunit le personnel et il dit y en at il
parmi vous qui ont des difficultés
particulières familiale de santé etc
si c'est le cas voilà cette dame que
vous voyez à côté de moi elle est
chargée de régler les choses pour que
vous puissiez être le mieux possible
dans cette nouvelle entreprise que j'ai
acheté pour pas grand chose et que je
compte rendre à son dynamisme anciens en
réalité la dame était fait pour
licencier les gens qui sont venus les
uns après les autres si je puis dire
ceux dénoncés comme ayant des problèmes
particuliers et ensuite encore des
années plus tard les chaînes
la formation continue se disputent
l'honneur d'avoir bernard tapie pour
commenter le mouvement des gilets jaunes
bel et gilet jaune c'est les gens comme
tapie qui les ont mis dans la rue c'est
les gens qui les ont traités comme il a
traité les gens des piles vander ajoutez
à ça la campagne qu'il avait fait avec
christiane taubira ceux qui ne faut
jamais oublier et qui a abouti à sortir
michel rocard du jeu politique je pense
que ça suffit pour avoir sur bernard
tapie une opinion qui n'est pas du tout
une opinion séduite c'est maxime légal
et je le disais vous appartenez un
opaque socialiste bat inquiété par ses
proches du ps parce que françois
mitterrand l'aimé beaucoup est ce que
vous pensez qu'avec le recul il a fait
du bien à la gauche à ces années là ou
plutôt du mal non certainement pas du
bien ça a été évoqué un instant d'abord
il ya eu des époques et des personnages
qui n'ont pas toujours été profitable au
parti socialiste est tapie a été alors
quelques fois l'instrument de bataille
interne vous avez évoqué effectivement
le conflit entre recart et mitterrand et
on voit aujourd'hui qu'il a lui-même
était souvent capacité d'
instrumentaliser les autres je crois que
pour revenir à cette affaire juge bien
trop vous et vous expliquer qu' il était
dans la confusion est compris entre ce
qui était du domaine du privé de son de
la multi 2 milliards de l'ensemble des
dimensions
de son propre personnage je crois que
c'est un homme de confusion est ce qu'il
va être peut-être intéressant dans le
procès ce qu'on peut en retenir puisque
je partage votre avis je crois que la
question de voir si il est fautif ou pas
me semble assez clair ça va être de
regarder jusqu'à quel point et à quel
niveau il a réussi à instrumentaliser
une partie du pouvoir pour poussan
propres intérêts c'est ça vous la vie
qui est l'élément le plus intéressant
j'ai quand même des responsables aux
examens
certains anciens os fonctionne certain
qu'ils ne pourront pas s'exprimer
puisque en l'occurrence nicolas sarkozy
a refusé
il avait l'immunité à ce moment-là due à
sa fonction
mais effectivement ce qui va être
intéressant de voir c'est qu'on va nous
dire sur la façon dont il a pu et bien
instrumentalisé et s'appuyer sur
différents acteurs c'est ça mon avis le
l'intérêt politique signant l'un de ce
procès la personne de tapis moi je
trouve que le mécanisme est intéressant
parce que les juges arbitraux étaient
trois dont un qui est soupçonné de
collusion avec bernard tapie mais les
deux autres qui sont pierre mazeaud
gaullistes historiques et jean denis
bredin explique que le troisième faisait
tellement bien le boulot tellement vite
que ils ont préféré préféré le laisser
faire bon temps en temps quand on est
censé accomplir une mission est une
mission importante pour préserver et
extrêmement bien rémunérés pour
préserver l'intérêt des contribuables
on est à pau - léger normalement oui à
beaulieu c'est certain qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de négligence au delà même de
christine lagarde nous internautes sont
assez partagés sur ce dossier nicole
willis est très compliquée à suivre
mais à mon avis c'est le crédit lyonnais
qui a escroqué bernard tapie qui n'est
pas mon idole ajoute-t-elle
révoltons nous dit à l'origine c'est le
crédit lyonnais qui a escroqué tapis à
l'occasion de la vente d'adidas
alors même que babineau lui dit je suis
un peu lassé de la médiatisation de ce
personnage controversé et sulfureux
empêtré dans plusieurs affaires et le
même révolte on nous dit comment
reproché à christine lagarde de ne pas
avoir fait un recours
puisqu'il n'y avait pas d'appel possible
aucune cohérence dans ce dossier wallon
rappelle que le principe de l'arbitrage
c'est que les différentes parties
acceptent de se soumettre à des arbitres
et à respecter leurs décisions alors on
vous pose la question sur twitter procès
pour escroquerie
bernard tapie vous fait-il de la peine
et après je vous expliquerai pourquoi
vous la poser de questions et vous êtes
quand même un tiers répondre que oui
puisque on le disait dans lattaquié est
atteint d'un cancer qui est grave il a
annoncé qu'il suspendait son traitement
le temps du procès à cause des
conséquences de ce traitement qui
pouvait altérer son jugement
est ce que vous êtes choqué par le fait
qu' il fasse état de sa santé ce que ça
vient parasiter le procès que donc il
devrait garder ça pour lui ou ou est ce
que ben après tout l'accusé utilisent
tous les tous les arguments qui peuvent
philippe meyer non on accuse et utilise
tous les heures qui vont occuper ça ça
me paraît tout à fait normal
ce qui me semble quand même c'est que
quand on met à ce point en avant cette
situation pour elle qu'elle soit c'est
qu'on n'est pas très sûr de son dossier
et qu'on cherche à attirer l'attention
sur autre chose que le dossier lui même
mais pour le reste c'est si j'ose dire
le devoir d'en accuser comme celle de
voir un prisonnier de s'évader
c'est le devoir d'un accusé de faire feu
de tout bois ça vous choque pas cette
cette confusion des genres entre ma
situation personnelle qui évidemment est
douloureux personnage il faut rappeler
d'ailleurs parce que on disait qu'ils
avaient des sympathies au ps non vous
rappelez vous à l'époque quand
mitterrand voit en lui l'occasion de
faire battre michel rocard pierre mauroy
et le premier secrétaire et dis-moi
tapis c'est pas ma tasse de thé
et il le dit parce que réputation
sulfureuse de racheter des entreprises
pour rien de les revendre avec beaucoup
de profits après avoir totalement
dégraisser mais aussi parce que dès
cette époque là on est dans les années
95 92 95 dès cette époque le ps commence
à avoir un gros problème avec les
classes populaires
un problème que dénonce tapis là vous
avez parlé du livre de boucher que
j'avais lu à l'époque complètement
complètement à charge or l'uci si vous
pouvez dire que tu as pu manger des
petits enfants plus le soir avant
d'aller se coucher il l'aurait leur ai
écrit mais il faut pas oublier qu'elle
tapis parler de choisir que le boucher
avec eux physiquement de maçonnerie
sociale et elle ne dispose pas bien
parti nationaliste a poussé son enquête
oui et
et à cette époque tapie par les peuples
pour aps qu elle est complètement perdue
de vue le peuple oui c'est quoi mais
effectivement je suis trompé en disant
qu'il était proche parce qu'ils étaient
proches de mitterrand qu'il avait imposé
au parti socialiste et conques et au
gouvernement d' ailleurs je rappelle que
mitterrand avait essayé de le pousser
dans le gouvernement rocard et que
rarement n'avait pas vous dire je sais
très bien qu'ils avaient dit aux gars
que exactement de la phrase était membre
du parti socialiste d'ailleurs membre du
gouvernement de michel rocard
tony dreyfus camidi arrancars michel
rocard ne prends pas cet avis qui dans
son gouvernement
j'ai l'impression quand même dedans
c'était un terrible gâchis parce que
l'homme d'affaires d'1 à tapis moi-même
apparaît comme un homme assez talentueux
et finalement racheter des boîtes qui
vont mal géré mettre sur ce que tu
allais pour les revendre je veux dire
c'est quelque chose qui moi me paraît
quand même assez remarquable je me
demande si monsieur tapie n'aurait pas
dû finalement rester à l'écart de la
politique et se contenter d'être un
homme d'affaires qui est un homme
d'affaires qui aurait sans doute fait
beaucoup plus de bien à la collectivité
que qu'en entrant en politique
voilà et je propose de terminer avec ce
jugement sévère c'est vrai mais il lui
appartient de yoann qui nous dit les sdf
me font de la peine louis mais pas tapie
je vous le disais la république en
marche a présenté hier ses propositions
dans le cadre du grand débat proposition
intéressante puisqu'elle émane du parti
politique qui soutient le président de
la république alors parmi ces
propositions il y a l'augmentation de
l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière qui
devrait être selon stanislas guérini le
patron du parti
la contrepartie de la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation dont vous savez que
elle est amenée à la télé été supprimés
pour la majorité des contribuables et
que le pouvoir a promis que ce serait
aussi le cas pour les autres et donc
puisque on baisse un impôt d'un côté pas
pourquoi on augmenterait pas un autre
écoutez stanislas guérini les plus
grandes fortunes
els tirons aussi un avantage de cette
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
complète si nous allons au bout et c'est
la raison